star in Mark Andrews with his
graduation is on the way in
this was one of those games
where it was just you never
knew what was going to happen
next how would you describe
this game from your perspective
just a fight you know one of
those divisional games M & T
Bank
was Pac-Man loud ready to go
but I'm going to beat the
mission what games do we need
to know we needed to spend but
we got a big one Pittsburgh
this week that you guys are so
confident in Lamar Jackson he
throws for Inception but yet he
comes back and continues that
he's the ball down the field
nothing changes in his
mentality nothing changes with
you guys it's just trust man we
preach it all the
time and we talked about all the
time just trust restaurants
start practicing in practice man
whatever happens happens
and someone give you guys any
different look that you weren't
expected because I know this out
there they had seven
defensive backs and had Jeremiah
spying on Lamar yah mean they
were floating around obviously
those guys up front up the block
and we know we kind of
had to handle them but your
current event played a really
good game it'll be a good one in
two weeks of the biggest
plays
in this entire football game
we're scrambling or where
you're making a play on the back
end of it so what's your
strategy when the bar start
scrambling around scrambling to
make it a play extending plays
and just find a way to you know
just make something
happen for you beat me to find
one of those dead spots
hopefully one of Defenders drops
you and you know just try
to always make eye contact with
a message to use it as
a receiver that you guys man as
a team you guys have overcome
so much adversity
are you to go through adversity
how do you guys continue to be
resilient and to overcome that
adversity we come to work each
and every week no matter what
happens you know where we're
going to get better but like you
said we've got a lot of
things happened to this year but
the resilience of this team
wear bunch of Fighters we're
going to keep on going to keep
on getting better each and every
weekend and you know
Skies willing to talk about Mark
Andrews but we got to give
props
that defense that defense was
outstanding flying around
making plays passion us
incredible man just shot it to
them that they sealed the game
for us so do you have some
young wide receivers on the
outside this passing game as
well it's been like watching
them grow
up sure you did when you got
guys like to come and look over
look after Sammy Watkins I think
it's been huge on
the rashod Bateman is playing
above his ears and then I've got
to
crochet your Tylan Wallace all
those guys man that they're
really
really good it's a dangerous
group what was the game plan on
coming in
as you know we like we like to
pound the ball also like to
throw it so you know rpos in a
run the rock doing the thing in
the chateau wine and they did a
great job on that one part
about playing for Coach Harbaugh
you
know the values of life the good
things you know how to
live your life and its you know
what it's spreads its you know
it's one of those things where
we try to take how to take out
there and he's a great man crate
coach he's
a type of head coach you want to
play for Wellmark thank you
so much man and keep ball and
brother will see you in a few